to get to your first 1 000 subscribers
do you feel like you're overwhelmed when
it comes to trying to figure out this
whole youtube things and you just really
want the fast track you just want
someone to just tell you like it is well
in today's video i'm going to be walking
you through the five tips to getting to
your first
1 000 subscribers and i'm going to share
with you some of our students who are
getting success just like larry larry
got 1 000 subscribers in 10
days and i pulled up his analytics so
you could see this he applied these five
tips that we i'm going to give you today
and he was able to increase his
subscribers by 1 000 in just 10 days
let's go ahead and get into tip number
one and that is
to
know your who
and your how write this down if you're
taking notes in this video you need to
know your who and know your
how and what this really means is you
know you need to know who you're talking
to meaning that if you're just creating
videos on youtube just to create videos
then that's totally fine this might not
be for you but if you're serious about
wanting to make an impact on youtube if
you're serious about wanting to figure
out how you can maybe leave your job to
become full-time as a content creator if
you're serious about really wanting to
figure out how to unlock the passive
income that can happen online then you
have to understand who you're talking to
and if you're trying to talk to everyone
you probably have a harder time making
it through to get to the people that
actually want what you have to offer so
in the world of marketing this is called
knowing your niche or knowing your niche
and this just means that you need to
know who you're talking to and how are
you helping them so if you can answer
these two questions it makes
understanding how to break through to
your first 1000 a whole lot simpler
because you'll know exactly who should
be watching your videos and how you can
help them and what this can look like is
uh this is cami from the plant-based
kitchen now cami's on youtube she's made
it past her 1 000 subscribers because
she understands the who and the how cami
is doing a vegan cooking channel and not
just vegan cooking channel simple vegan
recipes for new vegan like new people to
vegan food right so with the with this
type of channel cami knows exactly who
she's talking to she's not talking to
people who want a barbecue she's talking
to people who understand and want to
learn how to cook vegan meals or this is
sean sean chandler has a movie review
channel how cool would it be if you
could review movies all day as your job
well that's what shawn gets to do
because he actually has a channel where
he is talking specifically to movie
geeks now can i let you on a secret i am
probably not his who i'm not a huge
movie fan and i don't really geek out on
a lot of the different movies but sean
has a who he knows who he's talking to
and how is he helping them he's talking
about all of the ins and outs he's
giving all the pieces of the movies and
sean was able to not only get to his
first 1000 subscribers but he was able
to actually go full time on youtube
because of the power of understanding
his who
and we have allison allison does
watercolor paintings and she's an
amazing artist now if you're not
artistic at all or you don't really have
an interest in art you're probably not
her who but alison has found her who and
how she helps them is with beginner
tutorials on understanding how to do
watercolors specifically so not arts and
crafts she's doing watercolors
specifically so my power question to you
is
who do you help and how do you help them
who do you help and how do you help them
and understanding this is key in
understanding and unlocking the next
pieces of youtube i'm going to get to my
next tips and so much more right after
this
[Music]
hey what's up my name is heather torres
and i'm the host of the youtube made
simple show author of the book youtube
made simple and in this video i'm
walking you through the five steps to
getting to your first 1000 subscribers
let me know in the comment section how
many subscribers do you have right now
i'd love to know that so i can know how
i can help you even more because i'll
know exactly where you're at we already
went through tip number one which was to
know your who and how you help them and
i want to let you know that right now we
actually have an incredible deal on our
holiday special we are doing over 80
percent off of the course youtube made
simple so if you want to learn in depth
more about how to get to your first 1000
subscribers and your first 1 000 on
youtube you can go to
thinkmediasale.com which is what this
stream is being brought to you by you
can go there you can access not only the
youtube made simple course but some
amazing bonuses as well so if you're
interested in learning more after this
training you definitely can go to
thinkmediasale.com well let's jump into
tip number two and that is to make it
simple
make simple videos make simple videos
can you type that in the chat for me if
you're watching live right now i think
sometimes as content creators we like to
make everything over complicated like
raise your hand if you're like me and
you you you want to make it way too
complicated you want to have the best
everything you want it to look the
prettiest you want to look your best
right well we really try and over
complicate this whole video creation you
know what your audience really wants
they just want you to show up just as
you are and help them with the things
you know how to i can fall into this
vote so much because i want it to look
good i want it to be the best i want it
to fall into this perfectionism raise
your hand if you're like me and by doing
that i'm actually holding myself back
from being able to one make more content
and two help more people that's right
because that's what we're really here to
do right is to help more people to make
a bigger
impact and so number two is that you
want to actually keep
videos simple how do you do this what
videos should you be making to get to
your first 1000 well we call it asq you
want to be answering specific questions
how did larry get to a thousand
subscribers in 10 days he was answering
specific questions i'll show you some
examples of that but here's your power
question
what questions
are people asking in your niche
what are the questions have you written
them down do you have a notebook out do
you have a notes app in your phone
what questions are people asking in your
niche and you know for me i'm getting
this a lot now i'm getting things like
how do i even get started on youtube
people are asking that question recently
i made a video how do you start a
podcast
because you know think media started a
podcast a few years ago it's rising in
apple itunes we're growing on youtube
and so people are now coming to us and
saying how do i even start a podcast how
do i do this on video so answering
specific questions is what i'm trying to
do here in my audience what are you
trying to do in your niche what answers
what questions is your audience asking
that's exactly what mary did i love mary
because mary is in her legacy years and
not only did she pass 1 000 subscribers
this was actually an old screenshot of
her channel she is crushing it at over
500 000 on her way to a million
subscribers now mary didn't just get
there overnight she did it one step at a
time and what type of questions were she
was she answering she was answering
things like no
need sandwich bread okay can we just be
real for a second
that is a very specific question i mean
i don't think i've ever in my life
thought you know what i should not i
should make sandwich bread but the
moment i do need to know that guess
where i can go i can go to mary and
guess what maybe i'm not thinking that
but over a million people are asking
this question it's amazing to see what
you can do when you're answering
specific questions
for your who she's also making videos
like how to stock your prepper pantry
and she's crushing it on youtube now you
may be saying okay heather yeah that
works for mary she's like a million
subscribers almost so of course she'd be
able to get a lot of views on her videos
well let me introduce you to tony now
when i talk about know your who tony is
in the trucking niche that's right he's
a truck driver and he started a youtube
channel for other truck drivers and what
type of questions is tony answering he's
answering questions like how to drive
for amazon
truck drivers want to know this they
want to figure out how do you get
contracts with amazon he's answering
questions specifically like how to
purchase diesel fuel
and ones like road check 101 your truck
inspection okay he knows his who he was
able to make videos that are answering
specific questions while he's on the
road by the way so he's not doing this
from a studio he's making videos on the
road
and tony's crushing it with over a
million views on his channel i remember
larry i told you about larry who was
able to get 1 000 subscribers in 10 days
well he was answering specific questions
like is it possible to live off
dividends
how about the best inflation stocks
or have chinese tech stocks bottomed
those are all questions that people were
typing into the search bar and larry is
answering those that is how he's able to
get to
over now over 40 000 subscribers
now number three you want to show up
regularly
if you want people to show up for you
you've got to show up for them this is a
key piece in understanding how you
actually start to grow on youtube it's
not one and done it's not make one video
and then you're out no it is a
consistent
persistence
of making content that serves your
audience and this doesn't have to take a
lot of time this is britney and brittany
actually started making content while
she is a mother of five children and is
an esl teacher for children in china
okay so brittany is making videos when i
say on the side i mean on the side but
she's showing up regularly for her
audience one time a week she's posting a
video helping other mothers learn about
financial literacy she is crushing it on
youtube right now and is able to now
make enough money from her youtube
channel with only a thousand subscribers
to cover her business expenses now when
i say show up regularly that's exactly
what ben kaiser did he knows his who and
he knows how he's serving them and when
he does this he's showing up one time a
week for his audience now ben has
decided to go full time on youtube where
he's able to make more content and show
up more regularly for his audience
because of the power of staying
consistent on
youtube
but okay so you need to know who you're
talking to and how you're talking to
them you need to
know what type of content to create and
you've got to show up regularly but now
you're probably thinking well heather i
can't i can't start yet because
fill in the blank right there's always a
reason why we can't start yet but can i
just say the number four i hope hits you
number four is that you have to start
messy
how are you going to get to your first
1000 subscribers it's by just picking up
the camera that you already have picking
up the smartphone that you already have
picking up the camera that's sitting on
your shelf that you got three
christmases ago and never actually use
you have to start
messy
if you want to make content on youtube
it's not about being perfect but it is
about showing up and sharing your
message and so i hope that as you're
walking through getting to your first
1000 subscribers that you just keep this
in mind
every time i make a video i just want to
get one percent better
i just want to actually make the video
and then look at it and say okay next
time i'm going to tweak the lighting
okay next time i'm going to get a better
microphone whatever that is but i don't
want you to have it hold you back from
actually making the content there's this
little secret on youtube
that if you want to grow on youtube
you have to post videos on youtube i
know it's crazy it sounds really crazy
and weird but it's honest if you want to
grow on youtube you have to post videos
on youtube so can you and i just pledge
to each other that we're just going to
make the content maybe your hair is out
to the side on one of the videos oh well
posted anyways maybe you stumbled over
your words and you said um too many
times oh well we're going to post it
anyways because done
is better than perfect i can tell you
from interviewing hundreds of successful
creators that they are so glad that they
started that they got through those
videos where they look back and they
kind of cringe a little but guess what
it was those videos that made them
successful it was those videos where
they stepped out in faith and said i'm
going to do something different i'm
going to be different i'm going to be
i'm going to be someone who just does it
anyways that is what helped them become
successful so number four is you have to
start
messy and if you're getting value out of
this video go ahead and smash that like
button for me i'm on fire today we've
been streaming all day long i'm so fired
up because to me the next point is
really what brought me to success like
when i think about how do you get to
your first 1 000 subscribers and beyond
this next point is exactly
it so if you are getting value hit that
like button and i want to shout out and
say hello art for living out loud thanks
for being here hello uh devon thanks for
being here uh denise dart thanks for
being here all right let's get into
number five number five
oh no sorry let me show you real quick
some people in our community who started
messy i got so fired up there uh this is
denise and denise now owns an apron
business which uh denise started after
she started her youtube channel she is
rocking it now at over 48 000
subscribers but how did denise get to
her first 1 000 subscribers she just
picked up her camera and she started
pressing record and i remember when
denise first started she was so scared
and she didn't actually want to put her
personality out there she was kind of
reserved in front of the camera she she
wouldn't really uh you know she was very
soft in front of the camera but over
time as denise has put in the work and
she's she's gotten in front of the
camera and gained her camera confidence
from being a part of our think media
world
denise is crushing it on youtube her
thanksgiving dinner guide got over 8
000 views on it and it's so exciting to
see denise just pick up the camera and
press record and that's exactly exactly
what andrew finney did as well andrew
finney is a local real estate agent
and he just started making videos with
his webcam answering questions about
different things about interest rates or
how to buy a house and andrew has now
gotten over 33 000 subscribers as a
local real estate agent and is getting
leads every single day in his practice
because of the power of youtube he just
started messy if you go back and look at
some of his early videos they really
aren't anything to be super proud of
when it comes to the video quality but
the content is what matters and andrew
is crushing it now on video all right
number five number five you have to
invest in yourself
let me ask you when's the last time you
took a class
when's the last time you picked up a
book
when's the last time you actually set
aside time in your day to learn
something new
when i'm talking to creators who are
successful on youtube when i'm talking
to creators who have made it past that 1
000 subscribers
i can tell you that one of the
commonalities that they all have is that
they have chosen to invest in themselves
and this goes beyond just uh um
this goes beyond just the the the pieces
of like what traditional school says you
need to do no this is what is your
personal
development plan how are you learning
who are your mentors what are you
choosing to spend your time doing and
one of the things i want to encourage
you with is that here at think media we
have two amazing places that you can go
if you want to learn about youtube the
first is our think media main channel
where you can go and subscribe there and
we're a team of creators who are here to
help you learn the tips and tools for
growing on youtube we cover everything
from camera to lighting to editing how
to grow on youtube and then we also have
our free podcast which i want to
encourage you to subscribe to this
podcast goes into depth about topics
like how to deal with toxic people who
are unsupportive in your life what are
the new stats for content creators and
how are people actually growing on
youtube to over a hundred thousand
subscribers
both of these channels are free and
we've heard that these channels actually
teach you more this is honest feedback
we've gotten from our community that
these two channels are teaching more
value than you could ever get in a
university so i encourage you to make it
a personal daily practice to join us on
these channels
and like i said before we also have our
holiday sale if you know that you're
ready to go to your next step on youtube
if you know that you are ready to raise
your hand and say i just need some help
i just want to figure out how to connect
the dots i want to know what is the path
to success on youtube then you
definitely want to get a hold of our
sale that we have right now of over 80
percent off of the youtube made simple
course we walk you through the seven c's
of youtube everything from confidence to
clarity and even community with special
guests in there as well so you want to
make sure you get a hold of this at this
incredible value that we have for you
and again this is something that if you
say it's i'm ready for this heather i'm
ready to go to the next step then go to
thinkmediasale.com check out this video
real quick and then i'll come back on
and we'll get to q and a did you see
thinkmediasale.com
for the holidays we're giving you eighty
percent off our brand new youtube made
simple course bundle get over one
thousand nine hundred dollars worth of
our best courses tools templates and
more just go to thinkmediasale.com
all right well thank you so much for
being here for that free training that
we just did the five tips i want to know
your aha moment from those five tips to
getting to 1 000 subscribers and if
you've passed 1 000 subscribers i want
to cheer you on in the comments but can
i say thank you jesse for jumping in and
being a part of the youtube made simple
fam uh and uh looks like we've got rex
here from our vra fam john says welcome
sean says welcome and actually i am
joined by sean cannell the cvo of think
media my co-host of the think media
podcast probably the number not probably
he is the number one go-to expert when
it comes to youtube and youtube success
and we're going to be doing a q a a
casual q a hopefully here on this
wonderful uh uh what is today saturday
and we're gonna get right into that hey
sean how you doing today
heather i'm super fired up what's up
everyone i'm just grateful to be on the
youtube made simple show excited for the
youtube made simple holiday bundle it's
black friday at the time of recording
this but it's also think media tech week
which is just kind of our over the next
like seven days we're doing live streams
trying to help people with the deals and
i love those five tips as well i'm so
excited because i really believe this
next decade is going to be the best
decade on youtube it's not our opinion
we're looking at the data we're looking
at the stats let's get into some
questions if you got a question put four
question marks before
uh and and after the question so it
stands out we'll be able to pull those
on screen um it's cool to see people on
facebook heather we have ashley here and
dave and john if you're on facebook hit
the share button because we're gonna be
on here for a while answering questions
we'd love to talk youtube um and hit the
like button in the heart button and then
of course over on youtube um if you're
here for the youtube made simple show
let's get it to 100 likes i think we
could we're only at 63 right now but
come on we're going into the holiday
weekend i was just at heather's house
with my family and her family we were
wearing pajamas they already have 43
christmas trees that's not an
exaggeration out of their house we're
having turkey we're having coffee shout
us out how was your thanksgiving what's
your favorite thanksgiving meal uh
heather how are you feeling after all
the stuffing all the marshmallows on the
yams
all the turkey all the prime rib
like we
it's surprising we're here like it's
it's crazy we're doing tech week today
because yesterday we were in a
tryptophan coma watching arthur the
christmas movie
is that what it's called arthur
christmas it's fine and it is no
exaggeration i do have 43 christmas
shoes i did learn something though i
mean guys every time i'm around sean
cannell i feel like i'm just so lucky
because i get to learn something every
day and that even includes thanksgiving
i mean did you know that there is a
thing called a uh what is it called
china bite uh
put everything on top of the one roll
what's it called kyle anderson said it's
just an open face sandwich i just take a
roll and i put a little turkey mashed
potatoes gravy stuffing
cranberry
and it's a combo bite see it's all of
those things together i'm not are you
one of those people who doesn't like
your food touching heather looked across
the table and she's like is that a soup
did you just blend everything together
oh cause i kind of like all those
thanksgiving flavors all in one that's
just me i mean i don't know
yeah we are alive by the way yeah people
are wondering is this recorded this is
definitely live i mean we want to get to
your questions and so uh yeah but let's
let's see arthur christmas wendy it's
good to see you great movie i i i only
caught half of it because our
one-year-old need needed to go to sleep
but
um
uh so i'm excited to catch the rest
i had no idea that that was santa's full
operation i i literally thought he's one
person i didn't really know what the elf
did
that's that's pretty crazy we have
ashley whipped cream with a little
pumpkin pie i feel that and heather go
ahead and uh maybe pull the first
question as i'm looking through here uh
and throw that up we got uh sweet potato
souffle i feel you that's great and uh
sweet potatoes and apple butter man i'm
hungry again i already had some
leftovers for lunch but like just
conversation right here on the show has
really got me fired up but um all right
yeah we're going to answer some of your
youtube questions here we go
all right tea jolly thank you so much
for being here today how do you spot the
fake brands that want to work with you
well t jolly i think you actually just
said it right there how do you spot the
fake brands uh for me it's um the they
become like this spam uh um
wow i'm really answering this the the
fake
brands that want to work with you
usually will send you a generic type
email they won't be specific and it'll
have a weird photo and actually if you
type in that name on google other people
might have already recommended that they
are fake so um when you start working
with real brands you will definitely
know meaning that they will reach out to
you it'll probably be something that's
representing them and you will be able
to clearly see that they are a
trustworthy and real brand a lot of
companies will hire um vas on uh like up
works to reach out to influencers and
when they do that usually they uh they
will make it more custom it'll be more
of a custom type reach out versus
something that is very like you could
just feel it it like feels spammy it's
spammy that's how you would know so that
is a question number one and then we had
uh norma said when would you guys
recommend sharing your channel um
your channel on your personal facebook
kind of embarrassed to take that step
but i can use the boost okay so normal
mode tv a couple things you should share
right away like like here here's what i
need you to know
as you grow on youtube
people are gonna know you're doing
youtube so it's okay to just start
sharing right now get used to sharing
your content why it's gonna help people
right there you're either doing
entertainment information education so
get in the groove right now of sharing
your content now you said on your
personal facebook now if it's a personal
facebook and you're not using it for
business you don't have to share it
there if you really just want it to be
like pictures of your kids and your dog
and the food you ate for dinner sure
that's fine but if you are on social
media for business here's the
distinction i need you to think about
am i using social media for business
or for personal i choose to use social
media for business i don't really use
social media for quote-unquote personal
it's very much business everything i'm
doing is related in that way whether
it's the lifestyle or the content or
whatever that looks like so i'm sharing
things because it is a business now you
also said i'm embarrassed because i
don't want to take this step because i
or but i need the boost here's the thing
we really only want people watching our
content that want to watch our content
that's a big shift when it comes to i
should share with everyone all the time
all the places
yes
and you really just want to attract the
right person so back to number one where
it was know your who
it's that we don't want you know the the
um
the like for like groups or the watch
for watch groups they're not really
great because you're not actually
getting the right audience that you want
to see it and what happens is that when
people start watching your youtube
videos youtube will suggest your videos
to other people like them
so if you're not if the right people
aren't watching your youtube videos
and say you are a um say you're a
gardening channel and you're sharing
your video in a in a um motorcycle group
that is not the right audience to be
watching your channel you want people
that are interested in gardening to
watch your channel so i would just
suggest that as you're as you're growing
as you're starting to get uh uh more
traction on youtube to learn how to
share properly because there is proper
marketing for your youtube channel to
decide are you doing social media for
business or for personal and number
three are you using the right language
and the right uh marketing tactics to
get the right person to watch your video
that was a lot that was like marketing
business 101 uh
um school for you right there in one
answer for two minutes all right sean
what do you have
what is the best time of day to upload
on your channel well when you're just
starting the best time is to think about
the person you're trying to reach and
when would they be on youtube so if
you're trying to reach somebody in
school or are they going to probably
watch the video after school are you
going to uh trying to reach an audience
that's maybe has more time on the
weekends when in doubt i like to pick
the morning of the local time of the
audience you want to reach
um so they can consume the content on
their commute or when they wake up and
then you can get traffic throughout the
whole day that they're awake so for us
we post most of our videos on think
media at 5 00 a.m we want to hit the
east coast which is about 8 a.m which is
three hours ahead of las vegas where
we're at um and then get a whole day's
worth of traffic but listen
once
you've posted 10 videos 20 videos 30
videos you will then be shown data
inside of your analytics and this is
where you're going to want to go next
you can go into your analytics you can
go to your audience and then it says
when your viewers are on youtube and so
this reinforces what i was just telling
you but what you can see is that here on
our think media podcast channel we
upload our podcast every tuesday and we
actually upload it at 3am because we
want if somebody has a commute on the
east coast or they want to start their
day early with the podcast you can see
we have some viewers there and
essentially we get to ride this entire
uh
peak point the low point the whole wave
envision it like this
people start being more viewers on
youtube we want to ride the whole wave
and people can watch it this entire time
basically until most of our audience
goes to sleep and so we want to be in
front of that entire wave of traffic so
let me know in the comments if you are
already having this area inside of your
youtube analytics as heather gets ready
for the next question um let me know if
you can see this because if you've
posted enough videos you go to analytics
you go to audience and then it'll
actually basically tell you when to post
and i just recommend schedule upload
your videos for a little bit before your
peak time
all right the next question is is the
youtube made simple course updated and
always available well makers unified uh
this is actually a brand new course i'm
so fired up about this course because it
is for the beginner it's for the newbie
which is where my heart is which is why
i wrote the book youtube made simple
that's coming out next year so we
decided to put together a course for
that audience so if you are just
starting out if you're trying to get
your first 1000 subscribers and beyond
to earn your first 1 000
you want to learn how to film edit
upload you're trying to understand how
to get over the mindsets of being
confident on camera and if you really
want to understand like what what you
need to do to set up your channel right
then this is the course for you it's
brand new so is it updated yes it's
updated as in we just created it and it
will continue to get updates as we go as
things change on youtube and whatever
that looks like but as for right now it
is brand new and updated and you can get
80
off now your question also was is it
always available absolutely it will
always be available on our website for
9.97 but right now you can get an
unbelievable offer which is over 80 off
to lock in this brand new course um i
would love to bring that up for you all
sean's getting his other i'm trying to
get this up for you here while sean's
getting his other question ready to go
and then i just wanted to show him what
that looked like sean but go right ahead
yeah so this is a great question um
want to be a pro wrestler i have some
questions for the live stream does title
matter for seo as in if someone searches
my title and description or tags
will they find a current or even a past
livestream
you know i encourage you to kind of
study what we're doing here on the think
media podcast channel at this very
moment on heather's show the youtube
made simple show
we titled this video ahead of time we
created a thumbnail ahead of time
there's already tags on this video and
the video is already optimized now there
was a question earlier about what's the
best way to stream to both youtube and
facebook it's what we're doing right now
we're using stream yard and if you want
to learn more about stream yard
you can go to stream with think dot com
but
what i recommend is
is absolutely optimize your video and
consider the replay value
you know one of the things you might
notice is we're talking about
thanksgiving we're kind of hanging out
with you we're greeting you i'm able to
see your rex i'm able to see you andy
and we're kind of in the middle here
interacting a little bit more but notice
how heather started if you've been here
for the entire stream she led with value
and really we craft our live streams so
that there's replay value we crack we
craft our live stream so that when
somebody comes later even though we're
going to be here hanging out with you
through for the next 30 45 minutes or
whatever you know we're we're here
answering questions the front and the
title the whole video is optimized
here's the key for replay value can it
show up in search absolutely we have a
lot of our old live streams that
continue to be watched but the reason
many don't get that benefit is their
live stream is really only there for
those that are live but there's not a
lot of repa play value there's too much
fluff there's there's too much
interaction not a bad thing
but think about that if someone wasn't
there live and you were mainly just
greeting people and hanging out and you
didn't give substance heather planned
five points she planned a training
packed that up front and then we're
doing the rest so that's kind of our uh
thinking when it comes to that and i
think there's a lot of opportunity for
having um doing live stream videos that
are continued to be watched we have live
stream videos that are a couple years
old that have gotten over a million
views how crazy is that
that we're we're live we're real time
but make no mistake there was a lot of
thought there was you know structure
that went into it there's been a lot of
practice
in both heather my skills
we've tried to get better as
communicators over the years and when
you go live sometimes
you win sometimes you learn and that's
the nature of being live but absolutely
optimize your videos for the replay
value
next question comes from fluid art by
mimei uh and i want to say welcome to
the think media fam i saw that you were
just getting started on youtube i just
checked out your channel uh rocking 38
subscribers so the youtube made simple
course would be perfect for you
and your question was is there a lot of
if if there are a lot of creators in
your niche how do you grow and i think
this is a really honest question to ask
because you might be feeling like
there's just so much competition who am
i to be making this content who am i to
be stepping out and trying to do this
when there's other people who are
already winning
and fluid art by maymay i want to just
say that
you can do this too
when i think about alison who got
started on youtube and
i remember
coaching her a few let's see almost at
two years ago now and she is a very
soft-spoken artist she loves doing art
but she was so scared about just putting
herself out there more and we discussed
the type of videos that she she should
be creating and that was number two
which was asq answer specific questions
and when you look at what she's creating
right now she's creating 12 watercolor
mistakes
watercolor fall woodland collage she's
creating consistent content on her
channel packing our orders so asmr so
she's going with a specific type of
video so when i look at what you're
doing right now fluid art by mimei
by sorry i want to say it correctly me
may uh you're just getting started so if
you're feeling overwhelmed and you're
feeling like there's other people doing
this i want you to just focus on who
you're creating content for
when i think about you know there's
other female coaches in the world like
there's other educators in the world if
i were to say you know what i don't want
to do this i'm too scared to do this you
and i wouldn't be here today i wouldn't
have been able to unlock the freedom
that my family and i have right now i
wouldn't be able to grow personally as a
person because i put myself outside of
my comfort zone so i want you to turn
that energy inward and say no i'm going
to create for the right person i know
there's competition and that's a good
thing because it means people are
interested in what i'm doing so i want
to encourage you that you're three
videos in but you and i we're going to
talk when you're 52 videos in and 90
videos in and 150 videos in because
hopefully you'll be a part of what we're
doing here at think media for the long
haul but you're just getting started and
competition is a good thing it means
that there's actually people who are
interested and i want you to do what you
do best and that is fluid art so go all
in on it be consistent on it and serve
the people who are there to show up for
you
what do you have next sean
yeah really great question that comes in
uh i think a lot of us
ask ourselves you know what niche what
niche
should i create my uh content in and so
gypsy lola by the way that's one of the
biggest things we focus on in the
youtube made simple course it's really
built around five big
big categories the first is gonna help
you with courage and confidence and how
to get your confidence on camera the
second is clarity you know you want to
just like heather taught today
like who are you talking to who's your
audience
and how do you help them
that's really what you should think
about when you think about your niche
it's not just the kind of content you're
creating it's the person that you're
creating it for
like for example if you know your niche
is to help new
moms
lose weight and build strength it's
actually who you're who you're creating
content for could include fitness videos
uh it could include supplements it could
include mindset stuff but you're talking
to a particular person so i'd say gypsy
lola like who is it you're talking to
you know who is it you feel called to
serve to help and if that seems like too
big of a question
you are probably called to help
who you were
a year or two ago
what were you going through a year a
year or two ago you know uh for me right
on think media our main channel we talk
all about cameras and video
i remember back when i didn't know what
camera to buy i was overwhelmed by tech
i remember i took out a loan to start a
video production business and i wasted
about half i wasted about five thousand
dollars out of a ten thousand dollar
loan buying gear that was unnecessary
so now today when we do all this tech
and we help people
find cameras i'm helping sean yesterday
you know heather
is like the leading clarity coach that i
know in the world when it comes to
people getting clear on their brands
building camera confidence understanding
online marketing but heather a couple
years ago was on her journey of trying
to figure all that stuff out
and she was dealing with self-doubt or
dealing with trying to
figure out her message or even build her
camera confidence now she teaches camera
confidence she helps who she was
yesterday so think about your niche is
in terms of who do you feel called to
help the most and then
think about
zeroing in on um potentially how you
want to help them because i could you
could help people maybe you have a
background in real estate maybe you have
a background in art maybe you have dealt
with you've recovered after a
relationship that's broken apart there's
maybe a lot of different categories and
just for time's sake we will keep it
going with other questions but i do
encourage you if you haven't checked out
think media sale in fact we'll just uh
take check out this quick video this is
actually what the deal is all about and
this is what we talk in depth about this
very question
inside of our black friday sale that's
80 off did you see
thinkmediasale.com
for the holidays we're giving you eighty
percent off our brand new youtube made
simple course bundle get over one
thousand nine hundred dollars worth of
our best courses tools templates and
more just go to thinkmediasale.com
that also includes um our youtube
starter kit which is super cool if you
want our ti
if you want to be able to just perfectly
write great youtube titles by copying
and pasting after our most tested title
formulas where you can plug and play
your niche and your topics that's in
there if you want help leveling up your
thumbnails we have our a couple
different levels of if you're new to
thumbnails we help you through that
thumbnail course with some downloads in
there
your first 51 video ideas that's in
there that's all in the youtube starter
kit that's part of it
plus we're going to help you in the main
youtube made simple course get clear on
your niche all that kind of stuff and
this is no just beginners course only i
mean it's focused on you getting your
first 1 000 subscribers we also included
our youtube strategy workshop that's
four hours where heather tony omar and
myself train on some of the most cutting
edge 10 strategies for getting more
views growing your channel and so
anyways we're so excited about it 80 off
great black friday sale someone asked
how long is it going it's it's it's
gonna be available longer than black
friday so it's not like only midnight
tonight but it's only for the holidays
we're gonna leave it open just during
this kind of holiday season for a few
days and then that is going to go away
and the price is going to go up so
definitely check that out at um
think
mediasale.com
yeah and sean can i just say that i am
loving this holiday checkered shirt that
was just in the ad that's on today i
mean happy holidays from the from the
red checkered shirt i love it right out
of i mean i was i was chopping a tree
down you know so my logging career and
now i'm here uh blogging from from
logging to vlogging in 10 days that's
the yeah
have you i i don't know if you watch
reels as much as i do sean but there's
this real that's going around very
popular in in my
thread and it's like the carhartt sauron
have you seen that one the card i need
to oh yes
like
sounds amazing yeah happy holidays uh
wisco
um and uh and and gypsy replied she said
you said three things healing from a
broken heart
strong losing weight very strong and
taking a real estate course so i mean
now your next thing though is to kind of
dial it in but those are all it's
definitely like the clarity you're
already having is super powerful and so
um loving that and thank you so much for
sharing that by the way if you're
getting value we're so close heather to
100 likes we're at 92 and so i just
wonder with 135 people on youtube come
on y'all can we get to 100
likes
for the holiday and uh heather what is
our next question well sean i i've been
waiting patiently over here to answer
this question i'm gonna try and keep it
short but can i just say ryan is
speaking to my heart because
him and his family of five are about to
live in an rv full time okay i'm geeking
out because this is literally hashtag
life goals we already bought our trailer
we've got our truck we are hitting the
road and so i am right there with you
ryan not full time because i got it i'm
still doing this you know this is my
love passion and everything so ryan your
question is though how should we
approach starting a channel but i need
to know ryan are you a fifth wheel are
you a travel trailer or are you in a
class i just need to know at what level
i'm speaking to right now but here's a
couple tips and you might not be packing
up your whole family and going on a
full-time rv trip but these tips are
going to apply to you if you're just
getting started
number one
ryan i want you to spend about five
hours maybe it's an hour a day maybe
it's five hours maybe it's five hours in
one sitting and i want you to first say
okay
i am going into research mode
i'm going into research mode i am not
going into comparison mode that is that
is the that is the warning label of what
i'm asking you to do okay i'm going to
go into research mode not comparison
mode i'm going to give myself about five
hours to do this and what i want you to
do ryan is i want you to go and research
other channels that are doing what you
want to do and because i am an active rv
wannabe i know some channels you should
go and you should stock okay these are
some channels i want you to go and i
want you to actually look at what
they're doing you said how should i
approach starting your channel i want
you to look at what is winning and this
applies to anyone who is starting a
channel go and look at the competition
but again research mode not comparison
mode and i want you to look at a few
things that are happening when i pull up
uh this is um keep your daydream and
they are an rv family and you can see a
couple things they're doing right away
one they're answering specific questions
are you seeing this ryan the first video
that they have that or the video the
most popular video on their channel has
over a million views and they are doing
rv newbies top 10 things every new rv
owner needs
then what they're doing is they're doing
uh um payload problems how much can i
really tow so he's just answering
specific questions winter rv camping the
ultimate how-to guide not so tiny moving
into a grand design so they're doing a
tour and they're talking about it and
look at this they're sitting down and
just talking about it ryan they're not
going crazy so i want you to be looking
at what are the winning videos look at
this towing with a half ton truck did
you know ryan that you can review your
truck yeah you can do that you can
review your truck and any upgrades you
have on it whatever that looks like
newbie checklist newbie rv newbies are
you seeing what they're doing here so
that is one the next one is less junk
more journey now they are also a
traveling family and what they do a lot
of ryan is rv tours so they actually go
in other people's rvs
and tour them did you know you could do
that when you start making friends on
the road you can tour other rvs because
people that want to purchase these large
things right that that cost money cost a
lot of money they want to see inside of
them they want to review them so i want
you to be answering specific questions
ryan i don't want you to go and just say
vlog my life i'm blogging the whole trip
here's a tip if you're going to a
certain place i would research what are
people actually searching for in that
place maybe it's best foods in
charleston north carolina maybe it's um
top five trails in zion maybe it's um rv
family cooking family of five on a
budget right like you want to be
thinking about who's going to be
watching what you're doing and then
check out what their most popular videos
are but again
five hours max doing research writing
down video ideas and here's what's
amazing this is for everyone
you can use the same title
as someone else
so if you're seeing a winning title and
you can create the same video but make
it your own right you're not copying
them you're making it your own
you can use that same exact title
they're using keywords in that title
they're doing a great job in that video
so you make your version of what is
winning on youtube oh my goodness well i
just want you to know we are joined by a
special guest not only do we have sean
cannell we have
sean
cannell
lumberjacks unite we have the young gun
here he is
heather got us into these uh these
lumberjacks this is also the flannel
pajama pajamas we're in full holiday
mode man we're just hardcore in this
thing how you feeling buddy you doing
good
we can turn harder up heather
uh this is sean bradley kennel if you
haven't met him he's 14 months old and
he's about to touch the important
buttons on my microphone um he might
want his mom who's off screen right now
but uh just sending you massive love and
gratitude these holidays
and uh oh he's ready to head on out all
right well while you get him i'm going
to
okay
there we go i'm going to get to the next
question um wendy asks how relevant are
keywords and tags going into 2022 for
ranking videos i think that the number
one youtube coach on youtube seo should
definitely answer this one sean what do
you have for wendy when it comes to how
relevant are keywords and tags in 2022
yeah you know this is a great question
because the truth is
um
keywords and tags
almost carry no influence on whether or
not your video ranks like there's no
magical tags that you add to a video
that then make it perform better however
a lot of people are throwing the baby
out with the bath water and
unfortunately a lot of you know social
media and youtube gurus are kind of
leading people astray because search
based content and keyword research
matters more than ever
and it's less about using the right tags
but it is about doing tag research and
the better way to think about it is
keyword research as you mentioned wendy
ahead of time and so uh one of the ways
to think about it is you want to be
making
videos about popular topics and let me
just give you an example we talk about
um
you know cameras on think media and so
we could do the canon m50 that's one
kind of camera we talk about now here's
a tool i want you to be using it's
called google trends
i'm ty i type in the canon m50 we can
search to youtube search
and now we can see okay there's interest
in this camera in the past 12 months
let's go in the past
uh let's go five years even and we can
see that before the camera existed there
was no interest but here is how famous
the canon m50 has been over the years
and this actually is a good indicator of
there being sustained interest in a
particular topic so to your point wendy
this also would indicate that
if you make a video today this is a big
unlock for youtube it's a search engine
about a topic that is going to have a
good shelf life that's going to be
relevant tomorrow now you can't always
predict what the future is going to hold
but see we have made videos on think
media about the canon m50
as old as right when it came out
literally when it came out in 2018 and
those videos still get views today
why because of this strategy because we
were thinking ahead right
now
if we also then say okay let's talk
about a new camera like the sony
zv e10
this doesn't mean that this data alone
is not the only data you should study
but notice it also has not existed
during this whole time now it's the red
line at the bottom here
if we go in the past year which is much
more relevant for this camera let's even
go 90 days
we can actually see that
compared to the canon m50 in most cases
the zve10 is like a zero in terms of
global interest compared to the canon
m50 it's very popular camera but in
comparison it's almost nothing in terms
of of search now there was a day
november 8th 2021 uh and actually i'm
trying to say i'm not sure exactly when
that came out maybe i made it's been out
longer than that but
let's just throw one one other topic in
here though just to compare let's talk
about gopro now i understand
gopro itself is a brand much bigger
than just the camera models i mentioned
but if we compare gopro
to the canon m50 and the sony zv e10
what do we learn here that compared to
gopro on any given month pretty much on
november 11th
the gopro was 64 in terms of global
interest the canon m50 was only a five
and the zve 10 was only a zero
what am i trying to pull out of this i
am trying to suggest
that you doing topic research that you
researching how popular a person is a
product is a camera is
um
a tv show versus a different tv show
gaming what's fascinating is if you
research fall guys versus minecraft
versus fortnite you can see these
different trends
so what that would then indicate how do
i apply that to think media well
there's a lot of cameras we could talk
about but what we try to end up doing is
we try to narrow it down
to talk about topics that are going to
that we are passionate about but that
also meet
the most popularity
possible
and so the final tool i'll show you for
this and then we'll bring heather back
on for the next question
is we use a tool like vidiq
um and at vidiq.com forward slash think
you can get access to the the more
powerful tools like the keyword research
tool
but if we were to say let's look up like
electrical vehicles or something let's
go
eevee car
you know electrical vehicles right now
are incredibly popular so when you talk
about a tag this is a tag ev car search
volume 12 000 a month but now we can
actually by doing keyword research we
can say okay the tesla model 3
1.2 million searches a month
yes there's a lot of competition around
the tesla model 3
but there's also just massive
interest
that's my question for you is there
enough interest is there enough search
volume my friends
in your specific niche there's very
you know homeschool uh heather has a
channel on homeschool it it's a very
popular niche but it's much more
niche than tesla model 3s there is an
electric vehicle revolution happening in
the world right now it's a lot of
interest but a huge key is that
sometimes we're frustrated because we're
not getting as many subscribers or views
or we as we want and we have to ask
ourselves are we
in a market in a category that's big
enough and are we talking about the
right topics in our videos and then
honestly the final piece of this
is
because the question was how important
are tags i mean i'll let's let's make it
even more specific
you know
uh
sean there's so much competition
yes
but today i did a video on black friday
camera deals now i'm about to drop some
this is you you get this special flavor
because
these insights because heather brought
me on the youtube made simple show and i
just had my second cup of coffee for the
day
but this is like this is how we think
think media so watch this
black friday even with as large as a
channel is i think it's too big for us
to compete on
black friday like the entire
tvs
clothes target legos kids toys okay what
about tech deals honestly still a little
too big to compete on
because tech
tvs scooters drones
but what is our specialty on think media
and this is why we're asking you to
really think about your unique
angle your unique niche your unique
topic on youtube remember it's better to
be
a meaningful specific rather than a
wandering generality
so what is this video titled it's titled
best black friday
camera deals one specific thing and it's
2021. so so this is a current it's
camera deals it's black friday it's
2021. so now let's look at the tags and
we'll land the plane here because our
tag's still relevant our keywords still
relevant well yes
because this video is ranking using vid
iq it's ranking number three for bet for
black friday camera deals 2021 it's
ranking number two for black friday
camera deals it's not even it's not
ranking at all for best black friday
deals
makes sense it's when you get the word
camera in there we want to be a
meaningful
specific and we want to build the
authority of think media around a
specific niche like that here's the key
it's not that these keywords or these
tags ranked this video it's that the
entire video was
created
to serve a very clear idea before i ever
pressed record and went live this
morning
so then because these tags were here
they're actually just verifying okay we
did we did the steps right like i really
thought through i titled it well i put
some good content there's a good good
concept there and it wasn't that these
were magical tags that but the tags they
reinforced a lot of other things that
carry a lot more weight my friend going
into 2022 and wendy with the question
going into 2022
yes you should not give up keyword
research tag research but think about
structuring your content around one
clear idea that cuts through the noise
and your keyword research informs your
video strategy
build your video or live stream around
that and you'll see a lot more uh
success in terms of views and
subscribers
i mean did we just get a mini live
training course on keyword research i
mean because you're here on the youtube
made simple show you just got that
golden nugget from sean that's going to
carry you into
2022. and like you said sean there are a
lot of gurus a lot of coaches that are
just throwing it out and we're saying no
no no go all in on this but actually use
the tools that are there to actually
help you
define what your content is that was
fire i don't know if that was fine sean
that was fire enough for me that we
should probably ask
for 10 more likes what do you think
maybe come on yes
hearts for the facebook viewers right
now we're streaming both on youtube and
facebook right now i definitely need to
see those hearts going out because that
was fireshawn when you really break it
down the nuances of why those types of
things matter well i appreciate that and
thank you fam for getting us over a
hundred so i think i don't know maybe
we're on our way to 200 for how long we
can go here and and keep sharing this
out but but heather you know i recently
spoke at vidsummit and an employee from
youtube talked about this very thing
because everybody is talking about
suggested videos about you know kind of
trying to go viral about a
curiosity-based title about you know a
thumbnail that really gets attention and
we're all for that by far that is the
best way to go viral
on youtube but the key is
um that youtube employee was emphasized
so much the power of search and the
power of this and this is what hit me
really hard he said don't judge your
video too strongly by day one of the
viewership even the first week or even
the first month he said if you're making
videos that have a long and he said
shelf life
then your videos can get views for weeks
months and years to come and what's
actually kind of crazy is sometimes
people will say
you know maybe about
uh think media they'll watch a video and
they'll say why the video only get like
10 000 views you guys have you know
1.8 million subscribers but what's so
what's crazy about that is we looked at
our analytics and actually the average
amount of views we get on our videos
is around 80 000 views
but it takes and i don't know where the
old there used to be the little gray
thing it seemed to have disappeared but
notice notice this video on budget
lenses in the first
11 days it got 6 000 views so if you
judge it just in that first week and
here's the problem heather we're all
like this our emotions are so tied to
those in the first day we're like oh my
gosh it didn't it didn't go viral i'm a
failure right a couple weeks go by and
we're like is this even worth doing and
then eventually we start forgetting we
focus on our new video and every single
video we post we feel like we're getting
a punch in the gut because we're like oh
this is so hard and let me know think
youtube made zippo crew if you feel that
but man when you really catch what we're
saying
notice that this video
516 days later is at 76 views but keep
in mind we have not thought about this
video we haven't touched this video we
haven't shared this video we forgot
about this video but lit
516 days and you can actually study
think media's videos and see that's
two years later
the video that seemed unimpressive the
moment you uploaded it is still
performing
different niches have different
strategies but this in our opinion is
our favorite strategy here at think
media because why because for heather
for myself for omar and this is kind of
untalked about because our biggest value
is family
because our biggest value is yes we want
to work hard and we're working the day
after thanksgiving hustling on this live
stream but we have
margin we are not a slave to our
business
because we have videos working for us
two years later after we posted them
it's everything we do at think media is
intentional in terms of the type of
content we post the type of niche and
angle of content we post
i'm all for chasing virality but that's
going to be an exhausting chase that
leads to burnout for most and a lot of
times they don't reach it meanwhile
there's so much opportunity to actually
take a practical path to youtube success
it takes more perseverance it takes more
patience it takes a little bit more
strategy but if you apply what we're
talking about here friends you'll build
an asset for yourself that'll get you
views while you snooze views 24 7 365
whether you're uploading new content or
not views that's bringing you passive
income so when you're on vacation when
you're taking a nap when you're taking a
walk with your kids or when you're
writing a book like heather has been
writing a book how is
most youtube creators are such a slave
to youtube they don't have the enough
margin to work on something else
but when you follow this method it
really can get you a ton of leverage
yes definitely it's it's it's so it's so
the under valued thing sean which is
patience right it's so the undervalued
thing which is actually i'm going to
work this thing i'm going to really make
this thing happen and actually you want
to make sure that you're locked in here
on this channel which is the think media
podcast channel because we're about to
deliver a five-part series all about
taking the leap to full time and we're
talking about these pieces we're talking
about how just chasing for viral really
isn't going to satisfy you you know i
remember when um which was an epic thing
i remember when we crossed a million
subscribers i was like oh my gosh we're
gonna hit a million subscribers we
crossed a million subscribers it was an
epic thing and then the next day we got
up and we were the same people doing the
same thing and so it was like wow
i'm so glad we didn't put our worth in
this number that we're trying to reach
i'm so glad we didn't put our worth in
having to get these like giant numbers
all the time because how exhausting
right i would rather do the base hits
that help you with understanding how to
get to uh how to use your new um sony
zv10 with the you know walkthrough of
the tutorial that's on there that's not
sexy and popular but can i tell you that
the person that watches that and
understands how to do their content
right makes amazing videos turns their
family life around because they were
able to leave their job after they paid
off their debt and then is now producing
content and creating courses and helping
people in seminars like you see where
all this goes this is so much more about
the impact and so when you start with
just the small things like understanding
the direction of your video
understanding the patience and the
process of what youtube actually can
build for you there's a reason we talk
about youtube all the time and not
necessarily all the other social medias
that's because youtube is a search
engine which means it will work for you
when you're not working how would you
like that how would you like to not work
and something still be working for you
it's not trading your time for money but
it's giving value in return for impact
so i'm super fired up about that and
next up
we have wisco ted wisco's head says how
can i be more engaging on my videos that
might be the million dollar question i
create tutorial videos on tools to make
youtube videos wisco ted i know you also
said you're part of the vra fam you
started in vra and you've been with us
all day on our streams and i just want
to say thank you for being a part of
this think media community i'm so
applauding you for being there and
showing up and actually digging in to
learn and taking the step to invest in
yourself
is such a great thing so let's go ahead
and pull up what you have happening
right now over here and i just want to
see what you mean by can i be more
engaging let's go to watch this for just
a second and see what you're saying
just one click i can save you so much
time when making a youtube channel
banner and stick around to the end of
the video so i can show you the perfect
dimensions to upload your channel banner
on any device let's head over the
computer
all right so here we are at
snappa.com we're going to scroll down
and we're gonna create a youtube channel
all right well i would say actually
uh wisco ted that you're doing a pretty
fabulous job already i mean i hope that
you just saw that that was a great ho i
can tell you've been studying and you're
putting into practice the things that
you're learning you had a great hook you
told me exactly what i was going to
learn i actually even heard too that you
had some inflection in your voice like
you hear sean and i do you made it
engaging so how do you be more engaging
it's actually gonna just take practice
when i look at your channel i see your
three videos in we're we're going to be
here practicing we're going to be on the
football field at 5 a.m running those
drills pretending like it's game day
that's where actually the confidence and
being more engaging actually comes in
but can i just say you're doing a
fabulous job all ready and i just want
you to see because you know right now
like this is a great beautiful setup
right i mean i put lashes on today i
even like i even shaped my eyebrows and
put on bronzer who am i i mean what is
even happening okay let me just show you
though what it looks like after you've
done practice let me just show you one
of my first videos
you thought about homeschooling what are
the pros and cons of homeschooling
versus public schooling well in this
video we'll talk about it hi i'm heather
and i'm a homeschooling mom of two and
today we're gonna talk about the okay i
can't even i cannot even watch another
minute of that do you hear hi i'm
heather and i'm a homeschooling mom okay
oh my goodness here we go well here's
the thing
uh wisco dead it just takes practice
like getting more confident on camera
just takes practice understanding i had
to understand that i don't need to when
i get nervous
talk in this high-pitched voice that i
go to when i get super unnerving i have
to bring it down
and become more natural and actually
what being more engaging is
is a communication skill it's
understanding how to use your voice and
your language and your words your face
and your expression to emphasize more of
what you're doing but wisco ted you are
doing a fabulous job already it's one
percent better with every video i want
you in 10 videos from now to look back
at video number one or number two that
we just that we just viewed together and
you're gonna already see a massive
change because once you start practicing
once you start running once you start
understanding this
video creation skill
you'll start to get more comfortable and
you can start to become more engaging in
your videos sean what do you have for us
yeah i think we're going to take a
couple more questions here but i do want
to remind you that um we do have a
special black friday tech
week sale going on 80 off of our youtube
made simple course and um here's a
couple details because i know we're not
we're gonna do as many questions as we
can but i want to show you some of the
things that are in here
besides the youtube made simple course
you're also getting a couple extra
bonuses so we've included two bonuses
first is the main training there's also
our four-hour youtube strategy workshop
this is going to help you put together a
step-by-step plan for dominating 2022
with 10 advanced strategies for sending
out on youtube right now but i want you
to see this youtube starter kit
inside of here is the youtube clarity
blueprint our 15 best youtube title
formulas guide this will instantly level
up your title formula so if you're like
heather and i you know you've got kids
you've got a family you're busy you're
in school you just got a lot to do and
so i know that by the way this you get
lifetime access to all of this training
but you might be really busy you might
be like i don't have a ton of time to
study right now the reason this youtube
starter kit is so powerful is because
these are what are called swipe files
you literally can just plug and play
these titles onto your videos and
instantly start getting better results
you also get 51 video ideas to jump
start your channel
51 money making video ideas guide and by
the way
it kind of sounds like hype you know
what i mean and we try we understand
that in
this moment and where there's a sale and
it's 80 off my friends i'm not trying to
be hype filled here that guide
literally describes though 51 different
ways of generating money on youtube like
if we just take a breath
this is real
and it explains
different approaches that you have not
heard before for monetizing your channel
our mission at think media is to help 10
000 purpose-driven people create a
full-time living doing what they love
while making a difference in the world
with youtube
and so that's in there as well and then
also our best cameras and video
equipment sophomore list and our how to
create awesome thumbnail training which
includes more advanced advanced
softwares like photoshop but also more
basic softwares like canva so you
basically have everything you need
here's the promise of this program
it's learn how to get your first or next
1000 subscribers on youtube without
having any editing experience owning a
fancy camera or working on your channel
for 50 hours a week so i want to
encourage you this is really if you're
serious about youtube this isn't for
everybody it's if you're just kind of
dabbling and youtube is a hobby
awesome stay subscribed to the youtube
made simple show here on the think media
podcast channel stay connected with us
i mean everybody is welcome in this
community but if you're serious about
youtube if you'd say sean heather i
really want to commit to youtube in
2022. i want to challenge you this could
be one of the best investments you make
in your channel it's honestly going to
level up your channel more than video
equipment or gear because sometimes we
hide behind thinking we need we need
another piece of gear what we really
need is an upgrade to our confidence
what we really need is an upgrade to our
strategy what we really need
is uh that boost of
knowing the steps to take to get the
results that we are after so to check
out all the details you can see it on
the screen right now thinkmediasale.com
link in the description down below if
you have questions about it we'd love to
answer those we uh i saw a super chat
coming in uh we'll we will hit that up
and uh oh it looks like i have sean's
book thank you so much i watch think
media every day that's amazing i'll be a
full-time youtuber soon let's go and
great job everyone never quit improve
and keep going thank you so much for the
super chat super grateful
um and uh excited to um
uh answer a couple more questions
heather and if any questions about the
holiday bundle we'd be happy to answer
those as well i love this too uh ebm
scholars also said before their super
chat my first youtube video was a
disaster now i have over 80 oh sorry
yeah 86 000 subscribers and much
improvement from the quality of content
that's right right if we go back to
wisco ted you're on your way to 1 000.
when you get to 86 000 subscribers
you're gonna be at a whole different
level of what that looks like so ebm
scholars thank you so much for being a
part of what we're doing and being a
part of our think fam aj podcast says i
have a channel where i break down news
articles nightly it's growing but it's
slow going any advice sean i know that
you have coached
several different people in our
community who do reaction style content
like this what are some tips that you
have and then we'll close it out
yeah that's a great question and so uh i
think because i kind of maybe had some
impressions but i thought checking in
here was would be a good idea i think um
my first thought here your thumbnails
could level up i mean they're the same
in every case if you're covering a news
story there's a lot and this is i mean
my friends lean in everybody watching
you're about to get like a rapid fire
get something to write with capture
these tips because these are some these
will really help you evolve the impact
that you're making first do not label
your do not title your videos
aj hashtag aj podcast that doesn't
matter the date doesn't matter half cast
doesn't matter and the number of the
podcast doesn't matter
if any of that stuff's going to be in
there it should be at the end
what you should do instead is i think
about my friend ruslan um who uh he
covers kind of news stories a lot in the
faith world
uh but notice
how he'll
what he'll do that's unique
he will do
a custom thumbnail
he will
do
a title that's about a very specific
topic so he covers a lot of faith stuff
a lot of trend surfing influence surfing
like kanye west kind of stuff and let's
go to some of his most popular videos to
see how you could kind of pivot here
um
jeffrey tobin zoom link video so the
name of the person trending the zoom
link video and then he's reacting to it
notice the video length seven minutes
um so it's it's brief and it's to the
point and so
i think that the title should be topic
based
you should have the names of the news
stories the locations whatever's
happening
you should then customize the thumbnail
if it's about a natural disaster
somewhere that's to somehow be shown in
the thumbnail if it's about a particular
person in politics that person should be
in the thumbnail
um
the title could then be powered up and
if you want to you know study our
actual title formula for like our
podcast which is similar to what you're
doing
we do like for organizations sake
putting information into the podcast
title but we put it at the end so notice
it says
think media podcast 098
right at the end and that's it whereas
at the beginning
we have
a well-crafted title this is the kind of
thing that that
think media sale is going to help you
with too it's going to walk you through
all these steps and so you don't have to
be like well where am i going to learn
how to write i mean like heather and i
have studied marketing and copywriting
and
influence through words and all these
things for over a decade now we've
invested over 200 000 in our learning so
that's why we created a swipe file so
you can just swipe those you know
templates and use them so you can
quickly write better titles
but notice that that's front loaded with
all the value that they are going to get
the last couple tips i'll give you is
i would make them shorter i would
challenge yourself
um this is interesting i'm noticing this
good use of time codes and by the way
like when i see landlords refusal to
change preacher claims you know an alien
had sex with her interesting ice cream
manufacturer faces boycotts and vaccines
so i see
that the topics are in your time codes
they need to be in your titles
but the idea and opportunity you have
here is potentially
one story
or just a handful of stories and leading
with one story the model of that is phil
defranco
because he tells multiple stories but he
thinks about look at his formula who is
the most influential people that i can
put in the thumbnail mr beast and dave
chappelle
and and what can i lead with in regards
to those i'm so sorry for this dave
chappelle louis ck scandal like he's
definitely going on that salacious angle
justin bieber formula one scandal is
messy you see the the model
so
you have that opportunity to front load
it with the most influential interesting
headline and story
and and then potentially trim it down
and and where possible think about
leveling up your production value
because you are
uh definitely delivering value i can see
here but it's you on screen the entire
time if only you get something like
stream yard and you're able to share
your screen react to the blog open up a
blog website react to the blog if you
can include anything in regards to
images and videos that will help you
level up um you know the overall
experience and so
that's kind of a news channel master
class right there i want you to hear aj
and everybody listening
that was a lot
and you're doing great like you said you
already have growth so now small tweaks
will lead to giant peaks and your goal
is to get one percent better with every
upload but i also want to encourage you
don't let that fire hose overwhelm you
just think about how you can do
one thing on your next upload and
another thing on your next upload could
be improving your titles could be you
know
shortening the video a little bit or
just covering one story and
experimenting because i want to applaud
you and everybody who's taking action if
you're here and you're taking action if
you're here and you started messy if
you're here and you punch fear in the
face and you press record if you are
here see
a lot of people who have given up on
their dreams might even try and talk you
out of yours
but if you're taking action i applaud
you because and aj you you are
you're you're crushing you're posting it
looks like daily and you've been at this
now it's just time to take it to another
level
and someday you'll look back and you'll
say man i'll look at my original
thumbnails or my original you'll be like
i look at how far i've grown but you're
already taking action right now and i do
want you to feel encouraged and
everybody else who's posting videos you
can't steer a parked car
so you got to take action and start
messy before you've watched everything
media video or even before think media
said before anything post some videos
and then
start applying tips and stay connected
to our community if you haven't
subscribed to the think media podcast
every single week heather and i are
showing up for you to help you with
these nuance tips to help you get more
traction and then of course if you
really want to accelerate don't miss the
thick media sale as well so uh any aha
moments from today youtube made simple
fam i'd love to hear your biggest aha
moment you know heather talk about the
importance of action i mean we don't of
course we want engagement but there's
something powerful about writing what
you learned and what you're committing
to do why do we use the hashtag action
takers yeah i was i'm fired up sean
cause i'm like all right let's go make
some videos when i hear you just talk
about all of those things
and becoming an action taker is so
critical you should figure out what is
your next best step for aj it may be
that actually instead of going and
watching a movie marathon not that
that's what you were going to do aj but
if it was
rather than doing that what if you just
changed up your titles and your
thumbnails like what action could that
do for your channel what about if you
have been watching our live streams all
day and you haven't made your first
video what would happen if you picked up
the camera today and just made that
first video i mean becoming an action
taker is actually what separates those
that want to do it from those that will
do it and so i want to just encourage
you that if you know your next step is
to join us deeper inside of the youtube
made simple course it would be an honor
to become your coach on your youtube
journey to be able to be a part of the
process to help you become successful in
this uh in this youtube journey would be
such a joy for me to be able to do that
because really inside of it we're
sharing our heart we're sharing what
it's like to become confident we're
sharing pieces uh that we've that i
personally have had to struggle through
and and it really was because i knew
that i just needed to take action
sometimes it was messy
and imperfect action but it was exactly
the steps i needed it was one step
outside my comfort zone at a time that
allowed me to get to where i am today so
i love the aha moment from adrian aha
using the same titles and tags great tip
i love that so much uh and yep john
nacarado is helping us out in the
comments my book youtube made simple
will be out in 2022
more information on that will come soon
chris says my aha moment is to stop over
consuming content and start making more
of my own content
but i broke my lens so waiting for a new
one to arrive well chris here's my
action for you then what can you learn
that you're going to apply for the exact
next video how can you craft chris have
you written the scripts to your next
four videos
what if that's what you did instead of
consuming more content what if it was
actually dialing in your hook like wesco
ted did on his content that could be
your aha moment i love this one my aha
moment is to get over my fears again yes
we are here to help you do that i'm so
excited and chris and take action so i
love that aha moment uh
is giving the video time to grow not
getting discouraged with low views at
the beginning hopeful reality
hopeful
reality that is so true i want to thank
you for being a part of what we're doing
here at think media you can go right now
for your next step to get 80 off of our
youtube made simple course at
thinkmediasale.com and if you want to
watch another episode of the youtube
made simple show you can click or tap
the screen right now if you want to
watch another uh one of our think media
podcast episodes you can click or tap
the screen and we'll catch you in the
next episode bye fam